[Music]  we've never done the water challenge  before we were both coming to this  completely blind I think that I'm going  to come out as the winner in the  situation I'm gonna win I think you  might actually  good luck to you thank you  Cheers so now we're gonna put on a shelf  for the other one we're gonna try and  pick each other laughs one at a time  it's my job  [Music]  [Music]  i won obviously cuz you're more wet I  was gonna say even though I wanted the  not laughing I feel like I lost because  but I'm soaked down to my underwear is  there's a lot of cleanup required for  this so it'd have to be in a controlled  environment I did not bring a change of  pants it's really stupid on my there  this was fun to play I'm just glad I  didn't get us wet it's he did I'm glad I  left  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]